welcome to the University of Georgia
2020 virtual graduation ceremony my kids
one day
[Music]
ka candy sushi Cosmo joke no Kikuyu
Jerusalem visitors per day external
dioxo oh hi Katie as schools around the
world are trying to figure out what to
do about graduation during the corona
virus pandemic some have moved ahead
with robots and avatars here's how they
seized the opportunity and got creative
Ivan Campbell is a junior at the
University of Georgia I know that if my
graduation were to suddenly not exist
anymore
that I would be really really hurt by
that Junior Ivan Campbell got creative
so he came up with the idea of holding a
graduation ceremony in the video game
Minecraft it's where players can build
3d worlds with characters and
experiences I think that to sort of
physically be in a space with other
people even it's not really good I think
that that brings a lot to the experience
we have this really really big stadium
called Sanford Stadium it's huge you
know it can hold 50,000 people or so
it's where we have our graduations he
knew he could have built the entire
stadium alone and so Campbell teamed up
with other students we referenced a lot
of our school schematics that they had
laid out and we also used Google Maps
who looks through these to get an idea
of what the spatial dimensions need to
look like within the game
Campbell says there were lots of late
nights with the team over the three
weeks it took to build the stadium
virtually
[Music]
I've also become a little bit closer
with a lot of the other people it sort
of brings us together as a good job I
though the school is holding the
official ceremony in October the
administration gave Campbell the
blessing to move ahead so on the big day
more than a dozen students got ready at
home and showed up on the virtual campus
you are part of history this is a year
no one will ever forget
[Laughter]
class of 2020 is going to be very
memorable I do not think we are some
universities have not wanted to postpone
or cancel ceremonies all together so
this school came up with the idea of
using robots our BBT university is 100%
online
Sugoi yanaka is a professor at the
business breakthrough university in
tokyo our university have the graduation
ceremony once a year it's important but
this time in Okolona viral situation
students couldn't come together this
fully online graduation ceremony took
place with the professor actually
present at the venue just watching video
is kind of boring but the aborted have a
physical presence and making it seems
like human work actually do
about a hundred graduates attended the
virtual ceremony via videoconference for
them were chosen to represent the class
and have their faces screened onto the
robots heads yanaka said he's gotten
phone calls from other schools about
tips for holding a graduation with
robots we are facing this difficult
situation but I think it's a good
opportunities for us to discover the
possibilities around us Campbell has
noticed other students holding their own
graduation ceremonies in Minecraft so
many people have comments supported us
it's really really nice to have a people
getting together people are a part